ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns erstmal eine ankündigung
ansehen möchte sie darauf hinweisen dass
am kommenden montag von 18 bis 20 uhr in
raum m 210 das ist kompetenz sind um
ethik gleich hier gegenüber eine
veranstaltung stattfindet über das böse
und die sünde im film ich biete in
diesem semester seminar wird dieses
thema auch an also über die das böse und
die sünde und zusammen theologen und
wenn sie sich dafür interessieren wie
das böse im film behandelt wird sind sie
herzlich eingeladen am kommenden montag
von 18 bis 20 uhr
darum im 210 sich da ein vortrag
anzuhören über dieses thema
habe ich jetzt einen kleinen karton sie
kennen denn sicherlich also eher flach
wie oft klar klar die völker for the
last time to get the hell wie eine lange
sagt die dame zur katze und was wird die
what we say to catch woche hier und
jetzt gehen wir mal auf die hunde über
potato dogs ok
bla bla bla bla das fürchte jetzt mich
als eine these vertreten soll als eine
provokation verstanden wissen
es ist wirklich so dass katzen als hunde
das ist die frage die wir uns stellen
müssen also so kann man natürlich denken
das ist das problem welches problem wird
hier aufgeworfen was würden sie sagen
welches problem was jetzt im chronischer
weise behandelt worden
was würden sie sagen welches problem ja
nur schön
ja
ja also wir glauben die tiere wird alles
genau so verstehen wie wir sagen und
wenn sie mal die tiere anschauen die
sind völlig unverändert
na ja gut das ist ja nur die situation
aber jedenfalls ist ja nur eine
situation aber die schauen jedenfalls
hier
ja sehr stark und sehr nicht sehr
involviert
ja also es kann man sich
problematisieren das problem dass sie
angesprochen ist die sprache der tiere
sprachverständnis die tiere verstehen
sie unsere sprache können wir mit ihnen
überhaupt kommunizieren hier wird
suggeriert der hund würde nur seinen
namen hören und die katze die bekommt
gar nichts mit also ist es völlig
vergeblich der katze irgendwas zu sagen
oder sie zu schimpfen
das vielleicht auch noch wichtig hier
die werden ja hier jetzt kritisiert die
tiere
die haben ja irgendwas schlimmes gemacht
und offensichtlich sieht der cartoon ist
es so dass das vergeblich sei dass da
gar nichts ankommen höchstens im falle
des hundes der namen und das wollen wir
natürlich problematisieren das ist
natürlich ein bisschen überspitzt jetzt
das ist ganz klar dass nur zum einstieg
dann möchte ich sie noch hier auf meinen
quiz hinweisen
ich habe mir da so eines gemacht und das
wollen wir uns auch mal kurz noch hier
anschauen also
sie haben mir immer mehrere
möglichkeiten
ich hoffe dass es nett
verbindung ist ja damals dass geister
tiere quiz haben sie s bekommen von mir
per e-mail haben sie es gestartet oder
und wir können es gemeinsam durchgehen
wobei hand erste frage es gibt immer
eine oder mehrere mögliche antworten
erste frage wobei handelt es sich um
muss das heißt geistige phänomene
verdauung b qualia c intentional i tät
die internationalität
ich sehe schon das erheitert diese frage
offensichtlich haben sie schon eine
ahnung dass es nicht ist oder was es ist
zu dürfen gerne sie hat vermelden und
die aber es ist nicht die intention ali
t
wissen sie was die internationalität ist
aber gibt es überhaupt nicht japan kann
zahlen also es gibt es gibt als
intention ali t
was war noch mal das hier intention ali
t
wir alle
genau die richtige richtete geistige
ausrichtung und das haben wir hier
denn geht in pension
sie kennen vielleicht das unterschied
zwischen extension versus intension als
intense extension wissen sie was das ist
dieses begriffspaar
[Applaus]
also begriffs umfang und begriffs inhalt
könnte man sagen also extension die geht
er so auf die individuen die darunter
fallen individuum individuen die unter
dem begriff fallen
und hier geht es mehr oder weniger um
den sinn wo die definition also ich kann
zum beispiel sagen
schwan tritt der betrieb des schwan und
unter dem begriff fallen alle hier auf
der welt oder wo auch immer wenn ich die
extension anschauen wollen wir nicht die
intention anschaue dann wäre schwan
ebenso ein männlicher vogel mit weißer
farbe langem hals und so weiter und so
fort alle merkmale die ihnen vielleicht
auch zur logisch biologisch bestimmen
das wäre die intenze also intentional i
tät wäre dann irgendwas was damit zu tun
hat
die tatsache dass ein begriff einen sinn
hat oder ein inhalt hat oder eine
definition hat aber es hat nichts mit
mit geistigen phänomen das ist ein
phänomen das ist ein sprach sprachliches
phänomen kein geistiges höher
ok sonst noch was bist du nicht
verdauung
ja da müsste man eher sagen begriffs
vermögen also des begriffs vermögen das
vermögen von begriffen die intention und
die extension zu bestimmen das wäre ein
geistiges phänomen aber wenn man sagt
die intention all i tät einfach nur die
tatsache dass ein begriff einen sinn hat
oder eine definition hat das hat mit dem
geistigen würde ich jetzt sagen nichts
zu tun das ist eher eine sprach
philosophische frage oder nicht ja aber
sie sehen ist es recht recht verwarnt
schau mal ob das richtig ist ja es
richtig immer weiter warum haben nach
descartes tiere keinen geist weil sie
nur eine geringe intelligenz aufweisen
wie weil sie sich völlig durch input
output mechanismen beschreiben lassen
sie ihre organe sind nicht flexibel
einsetzbar
die ihre intention ali thet ist
fehlerhaft
ja
oder einigen
wie sehen das die anderen gibt es noch
ergänzung dazu zustimmung korrektur
ich fasse das als zustimmung auf ich
muss mal durch ja es richtig also warum
ist es richtig also um die karts
schwankt ja manchmal hat er so die
tendenzen doch intelligenz zuzuschreiben
aber eigentlich mache dass er nicht es
hat so etwas von dieser maschine sie
erinnern sich noch dieses canton modell
war einfach da geht was rein da geht was
raus sondern mechaniker sind so
zahnräder drin und so mechanismus hat
sie lassen sich eben durch input output
mechanismen beschreiben sie lassen sich
mechanistisch beschreiben das heißt
nicht dass sie mechanisch sind sondern
sie lassen sich zu beschreiben sagte hat
das reicht für mich mythologisch aus um
ihn kein geist zu schreiben zu müssen
warum weil ich das prinzip der
ontologischen sparsamkeit an sätze dass
ich nicht etwas unterstellen wenn ich es
nicht unbedingt muss und geist
anzunehmen ist etwas viel gravierenderes
als eine maschine anzunehmen würden wir
heute sagen ganz im gegenteil die karts
scheint dieses prinzip der ontologischen
sparsamkeit sich zu eigen gemacht zu
haben ja ihre organe c sind nicht
flexibel einsetzbar sagt er ganz klar
wissen sie noch mal was nach descartes
das eigentlich organist was maximal
flexibel eingesetzt werden kann wie
nennt das die karte
wie nennt er es noch wie nimmt er die
dieses vermögen hat er so ein begriff
universal vermögen oder universales
instrument wir brauchen also nicht
unendlich vermögen unendlich viele
vermögen um unsere vielfalt an
menschlichen aktivitäten ausüben zu
können sondern wir brauchen eigentlich
nur wenige begrenzte vermögen und ein
universal vermögen was in der lage ist
diese vermögens sehr flexibel zu
gestalten indem wir eben improvisieren
können stellen sich sofort unsere hände
sind ziemlich flexibel gestaltet wir
können mit den händen dann wiederum
instrumente bauen und so weiter und so
fort weil sie so feind sind wir können
jetzt endlich improvisieren
wir können zb dann mit unseren händen
instrument bauen einen bohrer und können
dann in einem baum rein bohren an specht
hat einen schnabel dafür da hat ein
eigenes instrument nur dafür wir können
sonst rennst du unsere organe sehr
flexibel einsetzen für diese zwecke ja
intension all i tät können sie nicht
haben weil sie eben kein geist haben
also wäre das keine richtige antwort und
weiter geht's welche der folgenden
thesen vertritt kabul hat ihre besitzen
intelligente seelen wie die tierische
intelligenz ist nicht zähle schon
organisch begrenzte tiere sind maschinen
die das beispiel der konditionierung
zeigt dass tiere über intelligenz
verfügen
was würden sie sagen
ok
neben
ja
doch was zustimmung kultur anmerkung
ja ich sag mal so also nicht seelisch
das meint nicht dass sie nicht seelisch
finster nicht seelisch begrenzt sind
dass die frage wie man es versteht ja
wenn es so wäre
tierische intelligenz ist nicht von
seelischer art oder so dann wäre es
wichtig aber hier ist jetzt nur die
sagen es ist nicht seelisch begrenzt
sondern organisch begrenzt ich habe
dieses begrenzt auch auf den vorherigen
teil bezogen also schließt sich nicht
aus andere mehr anmerkungen oder sind
sie einverstanden
probier's mal wo es ist richtig also was
ist jetzt hier für sie jetzt b war der
punkt sind sich dass ein tier einfach
nicht in so einem tollen körper ist wie
eine menschenkörper also eine tier seele
ist der potenz nach es gibt eigentlich
keine tier seele müsste man genau
genommen sagt es gibt halt die seele die
in einem tier biss und tierischen körper
ist eine tierische körper schränkte es
einfach ein und wenn diese seele in den
menschlichen körper werden wäre die
intelligenz nicht so eingeschränkt weil
eben der körper da mehr entwicklung
ermöglichen für das so kann man sich das
vorstellen seele ist seele sozusagen und
die konditionierung hat er ja auch
gebracht
da ist er ganz ehrlich wie der ewig jung
der sagt ja auch konditionierung ist ein
zeichen von intelligenz von causa
anschließen und das deutet auf eine form
von vernunft hin immer weiter welche der
folgenden thesen vertritt der ewig yuma
tiere sind lose maschinen b die vernunft
des bloße sklavin der effekt zehn tiere
verfügen über allen risko getanzt die
tiere können kausal schließen
fünfmal
b
[Musik]
soll ich sagen klicken die sagen die
anderen
wenn die fenster eines klar wie die
effekte ist dann ist die vernunft sich
so ein hohes vermögen wie bei descartes
dieses universal vermögen ja bei
descartes ist die vernunft die res kugel
kann es ein universal vermögen was über
allem steht oder sogar verschieden ist
von allen körperlichen und bei jung ist
es offensichtlich so dass die vernunft
nichts abgekapseltes abgekoppelt assist
sind dass die vernunft sogar eher was
untergeordnetes ist also dass die
vernünftig nach uns antrieben richtet
und nicht die triebe nach der 5 also
insofern könnte man sagen ist kausal
schließen etwas sehr niederschwelliges
und ich würde jetzt sagen schon das
ankreuzen kann wenn jetzt die vernunft
rieben allein summen die darin der
affekte ist dann tiere eben auch durch
effekte bestimmt sind und die fünf nicht
sowas hoch anzusiedeln das ist dann
könnte man das durchaus tieren zu
schreiben und das macht die card auch
nächste frage welche der folgenden
thesen vertritt donnell davidson haar
hunde haben wahrscheinlich gedanken wie
gedanken sind touristisch verfasst sie
bei gedanken holistisch verfasst sind
haben tiere wohl keine gedanken
die hunde sind große maschinen
stimmen sie zu
ich höre sehe zustimmung für sie kein
widerspruch dann klicken wir drauf und
es ist tatsächlich richtig und jetzt mal
gespannt auf die auswertung sie können
sich schon denken wir haben 100 prozent
wir haben ihn bestanden zu dürfen ich
gerne noch mal zu hause machen
so jetzt geht es aber ans eigentliche es
geht um unsere nächste philosophie
michael prust eine französin die ein
aufsatz geschrieben hat mit dem titel
das internationale team
das ist auch ein texte in dieser text
sammlung erschienen ist
ich habe glaube ich die folien
herumgeschickt sie sollten die alle
erhalten haben von mir
wir lesen jetzt einfach mal durch und
hier geht es jetzt vor allem um eben wie
sich schon anhand des titels 10 um
internationalität also diese gerichtet
halt
und es geht auch um begriffe das ist
noch ein weiteres thema begriffe haben
tiere begriffe verfügen tiere über
begriffe
das ist eine spannende frage mit der wir
uns noch nicht so beschäftigt haben ich
sollte vielleicht noch vorher ein paar
sachen noch sagen was mir einfach so
gekommen ist natürlich verfügen tiere
wenn man jetzt fragt haben tiere ein
geist dann hängt die frage die
beantwortung der frage davon ab
natürlich was von der geist verstehen
wenn wir unser geist was mentales
verstehen weitesten sinne
dann kann man die frage eigentlich nur
bejahen weil es dann weiter sehen ist
und geister kam sei natürlich tiere
haben phänomenal das bewusstsein
also haben tiere da ist ich glaube aber
dass das nicht eine gute antwort auf die
frage ist und ich glaube auch dass
marcus wild und dominik keller bewusst
ihren diesen sehr weiten begriff und
geist gewählt haben und zwar deswegen
weil geist glaube ich nicht nur das
vorliegen von einem oder mehreren formen
von mentale aktivität ist sondern geist
glaube ich ihr so verstanden werden muss
als ein zusammenspiel von verschiedenen
geistigen akten also beides schreiben
ihrer einleitung ist es nicht klar
inwiefern manche geistige akte andere
implizieren inwiefern mehrere geistige
achse zusammen vor kommen es geht also
um das zusammenspiel geistige achse und
das macht den geist aus also die frage
ist einfach die internationalität folgt
daraus dass sie auch noch etwas anderes
haben haben sie damit begriffe und da
wird schon spannend weil die frage ob
tiere begriffe haben ist hochgradig
umstritten ob tiere phänomenales
bewusstsein haben ist hingegen klar
natürlich das ist gut wie klar wir
können der im gehirn untersuchen
verfügen irgendwie schmerzen zu und dann
reagiert das gehirn so wie unser gehirn
daraus können wir schließen dass es
schmerzen empfindet das ist ziemlich
klar aber schwierig wird es dann hier
mit begriffen wie sieht es damit aus
sprache
es ist eine komplexe sprache das ist
nicht klar gedanken hängt wieder ganz
eng mit begriffen zusammen da wird es
dann richtig spannend
und da wird es dann nicht mehr nur so
interessant dass man sich jetzt fragen
liegt dieses phänomen wurde dieses ihr
wie hängen die gemeinsam voneinander ab
impliziert dieses eine geistige vermögen
ein anderes und so weiter ich glaube so
können wir den geist begriff besser
bestimmen so ich kann lese ich einfach
mal hier diesen erstens zitat vor und
auch hier werden sie wieder sehen die
ganzen texte aus dieser text sammlung
sind nicht beliebig willkürlich gewählt
sondern die bauen ziemlich gut
aufeinander auf das handels letzte mal
gesehen als donald davidson sich
aufnahmen mehr kommen das aufsatz
bezogen hat
die haben also einen roten faden der
dadurch geht so also es geht los ein
tierfreund sagt sie hält es für
vollkommen natürlich das verhalten der
ihm vertrauten lebewesen zu
interpretieren indem er ihnen wünsche
und überzeugungen zugesteht die seinen
eigenen ähnlich sind beispiel
beispielsweise schreibt ein
hundebesitzer sein tier jeden tag ohne
zögern die überzeugung zu dass der
zeitpunkt für einen spaziergang gekommen
ist oder schreibt ihm die lust zu den
briefträger zu beißen einnimmt sogar an
dass das tier fähig ist überzeugung und
wünsche in bezug darauf zu bilden was
die anderen denken oder wünschen
dafür genügt es ihm in der thier
literatur zu blättern in der es eine
fülle von anekdoten gibt sie berichten
dass ein tier listig den erwartungen
seiner artgenossen umgegangen ist das
ihn fallen gestellt hat dass es
absichtlich sein wissen an seine jungen
weiter gegeben hat wurde dass es
versucht hat die möglichkeit falsch
darzustellen um seine rivalen zu
täuschen
die meisten beispiele dafür gibt es
natürlich in der prima theologie zu
berichtet
die wahl das zitat die orang utans
gemüse auf ihren kopf legen um die
erzielte wirkung zu beobachten
einige weibliche schimpansen zitat gehen
in ihrer raffinesse ist so weit dass sie
sich schlingpflanzen um den hals hängen
um sich zu verschönern
ein schimpanse kann in anwesenheit eines
dominanten männchen seine erektion mit
der hand verbergen
ein weibchen kann eine versöhnende geste
machen um sein opfer besser beißen zu
können
zahlreiche autoren unter ihnen so
anspruchsvoll experimental forscher wie
die bremer haben behauptet sie hätten
verhaltensweisen der selektiven
täuschung beobachtet die sich gegen
unkooperative individuen gerichtet
äckern
also es geht jetzt um den phänomenalen
befund von bestimmten verhaltensweisen
und sie sehen wie der weges problem hier
angesprochen ist welches problem ist
jetzt hier angesprochen gerade jetzt den
ersten zitaten schreibt ihm die lust zu
den briefträger zu beißen
welches problem ist hier angesprochen
wie haben wir das genannt in der ersten
sitzung des seminares welches
systemische problem ist damit gemeint
[Applaus]
ja
genau da hat genau antikommunismus wir
tendieren dazu tieren absichten zu
unterstellen die den unsrigen ähnlich
sind und störten den einfaches ost über
das ist eine gefahr bei diesem ganzen
verhaltensweisen die wir natürlich auch
teilweise bei menschen beobachten liegt
das erst mal auf der hand ja wie sieht
es damit aus
diese beobachtung sagt sie werfen
mehrere fragen auf verfügen tiere über
geistige zustände wie die unsrigen
verfügen sie über wünsche überzeugungen
und absichten intentional i tät die
einen genauen gehalt haben verfügen jene
unter ihnen die geistige zustimmte haben
wenn es sie denn gibt zudem über die
fähigkeit die geistigen zustände eines
anderen und auch die eigenen hals
geistige zustände zu repräsentieren
das ist jetzt die frage die sich stellt
und diese frage hatten wir bisher noch
nicht so sehr behandelt es geht jetzt
also heute und begriffe und um
repräsentationen repräsentationen also
eine repräsentation ist sei ein
konzeptuelles vielleicht nicht nur um
den konzeptuelles abbild von wirklichen
gegenständen hat so dass wir eben jetzt
den tisch nicht nur wahrnehmen sind dass
wir ein begriff vom tisch in unserem
geist haben sollte eine art idee des
tisches ist es das möglich haben tiere
begriffe von objekten von der
präsentation oder sind diese
repräsentation nicht so konzeptuell
verfasst sind sie ihr einfach verfasst
das müssen wir uns heute mal fragen
ich kann ja stehen was er
also dass das weiß zurück auf den text
sehen wir letzten sitzung hat mit donna
davidson also überzeugungen sind immer
formen von positionen toppositionen wir
sind sie normalerweise pro position war
ein zeichen wo liegt das wesen einer
proposition sprachlich viel zeigt sich
eine position sprachlich genau das genau
und genauso kann man auch eine
überzeugung haben dass also die diese
frage nach überzeugung die geber ist
sollte auf die frage nach positionen
also also tiere können überzeugungen
haben das heißt tiere verfügen über
positionen über das zustimmte und wenn
wir so was vorliegt so ein phänomen wie
die proposition dann ist es ziemlich
wahrscheinlich dass dann ja
begrifflichkeit im spiel ist jedenfalls
eine höhere stufe sprachliche form also
positionen sind schon etwas oder auch
gedanke kann man sagen also wenn man
sich war kam jetzt ihre gedanken dann
müsste man sagen jetzt die meisten
forscher erst mal überlegen sind haben
sie pro positionen also gedanken lassen
sich der besten fall auf die vor allem
in die form einer pro position bringen
also es geht um diese frage
überzeugungen wünsche genauso ich
wünsche dass ich habe den wunsch dass
das sind also letztendlich vorrichtungen
die auf eine position zielen
da ist immer eine position im spiel bei
diesen ganzen dingen
ich beabsichtige das ich habe dieses
ziel und dieses ziel kann ich ein dass
form bringen das ist das entscheidet
meist gibt zustände eines anderen als
geistige zustände zu repräsentieren
theologen und philosophen neigen zu der
ansicht dass die meisten vögel und
säugetiere fähig sind repräsentationen
zu bilden und zur kontrolle ihres
verhaltens zu verwenden
doch niemand ist versucht zu sagen eine
muschel oder eine auster denke die
eigenschaft durch die sich diese beiden
arten von organismen unterscheiden und
die alle zwischen den kognitiven
lebewesen und den übrigen ansetzt wird
von den philosophen intentional i tät
genannt darunter verstehen sie das
vermögen bestimmter innere zustände sich
auf eigenschaft mit der außenwelt zu
beziehen zu richten anders ausgedrückt
intentional i tät ist die fähigkeit
informationen über die außenwelt zu
verbinden und in repräsentation
aufzubewahren um sie auf neue
situationen anzuwenden und das verhalten
dem verlauf der dinge anzupassen
ah jetzt haben hier mal eine etwas
weitere definition sie fast als
internationalität jetzt ein bisschen
stärker auf es geht um die außenwelt wie
man nicht sicher internationalität immer
nur auf die außenwelt gehen muss oder ob
man sich mich auch auf sich selbst
richten kann international also zum
beispiel indem ich introspektion
betreiben ja ich richte meinen mein
geist auf meinen geist wie fühle ich
mich denn gerade geht es mir eigentlich
gerade so
nicht sicher ob das nur was mit der
außenwelt zu tun hat ich sag mal so bei
tieren wahrscheinlich schon weil sie in
der regel kein selbstbewusstsein haben
aber grundsätzlich würde ich nicht sagen
also außenwelt als ich auf die außenbahn
zu richten und das wenig auf das man
sich dann richtet das dann auf zu
bewahren indem davon abstraktion oder
repräsentation gebildet werden wie auch
immer dann also muss er mit der
abstraktion dann einsetzen
ja und dann scheint damit so sagt sie
jedenfalls eine flexibilität gegeben zu
sein weil sie sagt ihren die können dann
aufbewahrt werden diese repräsentationen
um sie auf neue situationen anzuwenden
dass die flexibilität hier neue
situationen und das verhalten dem lauf
der dinge anzupassen da kommt eine
flexibilität rein und wenn man das ganze
noch steigert dann ist man irgendwann
bei der sprache ja wenn man diese
flexibilität nur hoch stufig genug fast
dann haben wir dieses universal vermögen
von dem die karts gesprochen habe sie
sehen also mit der internationalität und
der repräsentation ali tät können wir
sehr viel flexibilität erreichen
wir sind nicht auf bestimmte konkrete
fälle mehr angewiesen sondern wir haben
typen zentimeter fall also wir haben
kategorien wir sagen nicht nur dieser
tisch dieser hier sind wir haben den
allgemeinen begriff des tisches unter
denen dann ein konkreter tisch fallen
kann
affen haben das meines wissens also die
den kann man dann wirklich so ein
konzept nachweisen und allgemein begriff
und die sagen dann was unter diesen
allgemeinen bild gefällt ist das ein
fall davon dann weiß man sie haben eine
repräsentation
ich versuche mal da im video zu finden
aber meines wissens also höher also hör
stufige sagen primaten haben diese
fähigkeit des begriffs vermögens
die
die ausgebildete zu unternehmen
würde ich jetzt erstmal noch nicht
gleich sagen also nachahmung kann auch
wieder so ein bisschen in die
mechanische richtung gehen oder in die
instinktive richtung
es müsste halt schon sonne schon
wirklich geistige prozess stattfinden
anhand des beispiels der nachahmung kann
man nicht gleich sagen was es ist muss
ich eben immer überlegen könnte es nicht
auch rein mechanistisch erklärt werden
das ist so die frage wie man bei affen
dann aber dagegen diesen test macht
subsumiert mal ein konkretes ding unter
einem begriff also da gibt s concept
tisch und dann sollen die sagen was
davon jetzt darunter fällt dann weiß man
ganz genau dass es begriffs vermögen ist
bei nachahmung werde ich mir noch ein
bisschen unsicher das würde ich nicht
gleich als repräsentation alis
bezeichnet
[Musik]
franz
ja richtig aber sie sagen es glaube ich
zurecht begrifflichkeit hat immer was
mit distanzierung zu tun also ich
abstrahieren von dem konkreten und
nachahmung scheint mir doch zu sehr an
konkreten zu sein als dass man da jetzt
von der repräsentation sprechen kann es
könnte trotzdem wird es ist nachahmung
ist natürlich eine form von
kommunikation
das ist das ist ohne frage der fall aber
die frage ist halt die ob es wirklich
begrifflichen stadt das hat ja das
hatten sie sich noch meldet ok also mal
trist dahin lesen sie einfach mal weiter
sie sagt folgt weiter bohren besteht
diese fähigkeit zur repräsentation und
wie erfolgte erwerb von informationen
der es ermöglicht eine repräsentation zu
bilden oder zu aktivieren man könnte
vermuten dass die fähigkeit etwas zu
repräsentieren die fähigkeit impliziere
eine korrelation zwischen inneren und
äußeren zustände herzustellen
diese definition würde uns aber dazu
führen dass wir auch einfache organismen
wie austern oder schnecken zu den
denkenden wie sie zählen müssten weil
sie offensichtlich in der lage sind mit
hilfe einer begrenzten anzahl von
neuronen solche korrelation herzustellen
und in angemessener weise auf ihre
umwelt zu reagieren der seehase
beispielsweise einen ihren neuronalen
struktur gut untersuchte meeres
nacktschnecke hat atemorgane mit kiemen
die sich in einem mantel befinden
der durch eine schutz membran bedeckt
ist das ende dieser mentalen bildet
einen siphon wenn der siphon durch
berührung stimuliert wird ziehen sich
die atemorgane aufgrund eines
schutzreflexe zurück
was nun den erwerb von korrelation
betrifft besteht der wichtige punkt
darin dass der reflex dass sie hasen
durch lernen verändert werden kann der
seehase lernt einen taktilen reiz zu
ignorieren wenn er häufig wiederholt
werden kann
geholt wird und diese reaktion auch bei
gleichartigen aber weniger intensiven
reizen sie zeigen die seehasen können
auch dazu konditioniert werden ihren
sich zurückzuziehen wenn sie elektrische
schläge auf ihren fuß erhalten
all das verdeutlicht dass sie fähig sind
ihre neuronal dynamik mit veränderungen
in die welt zu korrelieren in der welt
zu korrelieren
zudem folgt das lernen zu dem sie fähig
sind einem zeitlichen muster das jenem
der konditionierung von wirbeltieren
vergleichbar ist ist nun die aussage
sinnvoll dass der zustand der
sensorischen neuronen für den seehasen
die welt repräsentieren als eine
repräsentation vorliegt handelt es sich
um eine geistige repräsentation
das sind sehr berechtigte fragen die mir
scheint
wie sehen sie ist die frage möchte ich
gleich an sie weitergeben
also sie sagt hier seehasen können dazu
konditioniert werden hier sagt sie das
hier ist das wort
sie können konditioniert werden auf eine
weise die derjenigen von wirbeltieren
vergleichbar ist sagt sie hier
ja ist jetzt diese konditionierung diese
basale neuronale konditionierung von
seehasen eine repräsentation oder eine
geistige repräsentation zu hören
stellen wir uns doch mal konkret
vorbildlich wie stellen wir uns jetzt
diese konditionierung vor
falls jemand von ihnen wie in chf
aussieht ich weiß es leider nicht
ja auch so also entlang des ganzen
das haben sie zu schlagen
ok also ich sage mal das ist jetzt
einfach mal der seehasen ja hast du so
so nah sind sie haase
gibts kommen da so reitze rein
dessen jetzt die stimulierung von außen
und jetzt ändert sich im inneren
er hat jetzt mal drei neuronen der
seehase und wir haben ein zustand davor
das sind in neuronen so angeordnet und
durch die stimulierung werden die
neuronen jetzt so angeordnet
also aus dieser 383 reihe gut eines nach
unten durch die stimulierung frage ist
das jetzt hier das text das nehmen wir
mal ex diese stimulierende iks ist
dieses simulierung ist es ist diese
anordnung der neuronen eine
repräsentation dieses ixus dieser reiz
mal
genau das ist genau die sagen völlig
richtig glaube das ist ein reiz
reaktions schemas ein bisschen input
output ich bringe den input und was
kommt raus die neuronen verändern sich
die passen sich so an könnte man jetzt
mal sagen die das problem ist folgendes
könnte es nicht auch sein dass wir jetzt
hier ein y 1 nur zwei pfeile und genau
dasselbe heraus bekommen dann wäre es
nämlich keine repression repräsentation
wäre also repräsentation bedeutet ja
wohl immer kann man immer überlegen das
ist eine eindeutige zuordnung ist eine
funktion eine funktion ich sitze was
rein und bekomme ein wert raus wobei na
ja also ich setze etwas ein das wäre
ihnen berichtet sie was ein bekomme was
raus es kann aber durchaus sein dass
dieser also wie bei einer funktion
setzte etwas ein hier 46 bekommen so
eine schöne kurve und es kann natürlich
sein dass das was ich herausbekomme dass
das an verschiedenen stellen vorliegt
eine funktion wäre glaube ich nicht eine
richtige repräsentation
ähnlichkeiten haben
in der hofmark aich damit könnte man das
gleiche
aber es gibt eben hier sagen voraus
klar aber ich meine wenn jetzt eben
diese diese anordnung hier dieses
dreieck wenn das eben sowohl das
repräsentiert x-mal und diese drei
pfeile und das frage wäre das dann noch
eine repräsentation gutes habe ich
eigentlich schon gesagt ist
repräsentiert das und dass es wäre
vielleicht eine aber keine eindeutige
mehr weil wir erwarten doch eigentlich
das nur dass hier führt dass das nur
eine sache repräsentiert diese anordnung
nur das hier und nicht noch zugleich
diesen reiz ja soll die frage aber ich
sag dir es repräsentiere präsentiert es
ist repressierten beide ist
unterscheidet nicht mehr zwischen beiden
ja so könnte - habe ich glaube sie haben
es völlig richtig sagt das ist also
input output und frage nochmals sie
sagten also keine geistige
repräsentation da müsste man sich dazu
noch verhalten der seehase müsste sich
zu sein
zustände wie verhalten aber der
repräsentation wäre es mit nichts sagen
ja es stimmt die anderen teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer zu sehen sie das ähnlich
geht die frage der dieser repräsentation
ist ja immer auch interessant also in
welchem verhältnis stehen repräsentieren
und er präsentiert es also das ist die
repräsentation dass es repräsentiert das
rap ist das repräsentieren
und das ist das repräsentierte und in
welchem verhältnis stehen jetzt
repräsentiert es zu repräsentieren
ja das sei jetzt alles vertreten
bereits jetzt alles ich das sagen die
ganzen äußeren reize und sobald die
jetzt ein einströmen auf diese
neuronalen neuronalen organe neuronalen
teile
was von verhältnis muss es gibt also
hier haben wir eigentlich nur ein
verhältnis nämlich kausal das verhältnis
haben causa immer wenn wenn das erst
dann passt das folgt daraus man könnte
auch sagen wieso ein abdruck also diese
äußere reize hinterlässt ein abdruck in
unserem gehirn und der abdruck sieht
halt so aus man sie kennen das alle wenn
man mit bildgebenden verfahren reize
also registrierten also irgendwie
schmerz im bein sieht so aus in der
gehirn landschaft da leuchtet halt hier
irgendwas rot oder besonders intensiv
frage repräsentiert dann dieses dieses
dieses leuchten im gehirn repräsentiert
das dann wiesen schmerz und die raben
oder die reizung irgendwo am bein
die fragen die schon es hängt damit
zusammen kauf sein
es ist also eine ursächliche verbindung
dazwischen frage ist halt ob es nicht
noch zu mechanisch und zu direkt ist
also ist der genug distanz tag ist
dieser zustand unabhängig sie sagten
auch kehrt er wieder nach einer zeit
also bleibt der konstant wenn wir eben
jetzt ein bisschen zeit verstreichen
lassen und das dann wieder genau das
eben alles was kommt dann wieder genau
das selbe raus das ist die bedingung
dafür dass es nicht nur einmalig es
haben immer ein
[Musik]
frauen gehen schon stark vergrößert
waren kein essen
neben positionen heute nicht vergessen
[Musik]
ja ja ja diese publish und da wird dir
dann letztendlich auch etwas antizipiere
fleißiger repräsentiert was noch gar
nicht da ist
das wird antizipieren repräsentieren und
da ist es glaube ich noch eindeutiger
weil nämlich das antizipieren
repräsentierte wiederum kausal wirksam
ist für den speichelfluss wenn dies
recht sehe zahl der für die frage
wirklich hat der hund eine
repräsentation dieses fressens hatte das
wirklich oder ist das nicht nur auch so
komplexe cholera
er muss schon eine repräsentation haben
wie davon
die frage ist halt ist die wirklich
begrifflich sagt er jetzt hier fressen
sagte das jetzt hier
es ist es ist eine position könnte man
sich fragen ja es ist die repräsentation
proposition ahl
ich freue mich jetzt darauf dass jetzt
gibt es dass es das
also ich glaube wir können sagen nach
dem jetzigen stand wir können
repräsentation durchaus etwas weiter
fassen und dann sowas darunter
subsumieren beim hund bei der
positionierung wird das noch deutlicher
aber ich glaube dass eine repräsentation
immer auch ein bisschen proposition ahl
strukturiert sein muss könnte man sagen
also beginnt das wird eine richtige
repräsentation muss diesen das diesen
dass diese das form haben und diese das
form ist natürlich was ganz anderes als
nur so eine anordnung von drei neuronen
in einer neuen art das scheint mir jetzt
mal gerade oder begrifflich eine
begriffliche form
dann werden wenn etwas nur das form
gebracht werden kann dann ist es meines
erachtens auch begrifflich verfasst die
frage ist ist das pro position ist an
der repräsentation proposition ahl
strukturiert sie ist einfach mal weiter
im gegensatz zu einer fest verankerten
meinung kann man nicht behaupten eine
korrelation durch konditionierung
erreicht wurde erlaube ipso facto den
schluss dass die die bildete
repräsentation keine geistige sei
folgender definition von geistiger
repräsentation die fred treske
formuliert an amerikanischer philosoph
des geistes liegt dann ein geistiger
zustand vor wenn dieser die drei
folgenden folgenden bedienen und
gleichzeitig erfüllt also jetzt kommen
die drei bedingungen die friedrichs kein
philosoph des geistes
für geistige repräsentation angeführt
habt
als er wird jetzt etwas etwas kritischer
angeht also gegen zur fest verankerten
meinung kann man nicht behaupten eine
korrelation also korrelation ist jetzt
dass hier korrelation ist jetzt das
verhältnis von reiz also das hier ist
die korrelation kann man nicht behaupten
eine korrelation durchkreuzen gerade pso
faktor schluss dass die gibt keine
geistiges als es ist durchaus möglich
sagt sie jetzt dass es sich hierbei um
das geistige st sie ist einmal diese
drei bedingungen von vertritt erstens es
gibt eine regelmäßige varianz zwischen
dem zustand unter gegebenen situation
das ist die korrelation co also die kuh
varianz ist also immer eine regelmäßige
gleichzeitiges auftreten wenn adern bär
indikationen treske diese art von
relation durch die der innere zustand
eine information waren äußere situation
oder eigenschaft trägt oder sie
indiziert als wir können davon darauf
schließen dass während indikation können
von der repräsentierten auch vom
repräsentieren denn auf das
repräsentierte schließen es wäre ein in
die kasse
zweitens der innere indikator dass die
drei euro
der eine bestimmte information trägt hat
die funktion die äußere situation
anzuzeigen
in diesem fall repräsentiert der
indikator die situation wie man sagt
wenn treske von funktion spricht will er
damit betonen dass ein auswahl
mechanismus allen bestimmten neuronalen
zustand beispielsweise allen zustand der
anti sie funktional geknüpft bis dazu
gebracht hat immer dann reaktiviert zu
werden
wenn ein bestimmter typ von visueller
form verarbeitet wurde
die frage ist wirklich diese drei anders
geordneten neuronen tragen die wirklich
eine information kommt der bericht der
funktion
also das ist eine funktionale zuordnung
also dieses ding wird das zugeordnet das
heißt aber nicht dass nicht auch einem
anderen zustand y auch dasselbe
zugeordnet werden kann
das ist wie mit seiner funktion ich kann
einem wert bei den wert zu schreiben das
haben mal das ist jetzt hier oops i lon
fix und ich kann dem x1 genau denselben
wird auch zuordnen
ich hatte mich halt gefragt muss es
wirklich eins zu eins sache ist sein zu
nehmen also dass das hier wirklich nur
einen zustand präsentieren kann
da kann es zwei zustände repräsentieren
funktional muss es nicht nur ein zustand
wird präsentieren können ja
die entscheidung
die lösung heißt
der 1
ja also hier gehen wir jetzt davon aus
dass für eine völlige transparenz des
geistes haben das ist jetzt ein idealer
zustand gewissen maß da gehen wir davon
aus dass uns alles klar vor augen liegt
ich lese man dem dritten punkt noch vor
schließlich müssen die derart
festgelegten inneren zustände mit dem
status einer repräsentation wahr oder
falsch sein das heißt semantisch
evaluiert anders ausgedrückt sobald eine
geistige repräsentation erworben wird
muss sie richtig oder falsch anwendbar
sein
jetzt wird es aber ein bisschen
anspruchsvoller sind diese 30 wohnen
semantisch evaluiert
können sie bar oder falsch sein
hier
wahr oder falsch können eigentlich nur
positionen zahlen haben wir ja mal
gesagt na also das formen setzte setzte
die mir das form sind oder gedanken die
geistige zustände die in einer das formt
sich befinden das ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig also mit 102 glaube ich haben
wir bei diesem seehasen eigentlich alles
bei dem dritten bin ich mir nicht ganz
sicher
das ist doch ein starkes starke
bedingung starkes kriterium hier nummer
drei semantische evaluierung leser
ja aber falsch ist ja eigentlich nur
dass wir sagen der stock im wasser ist
geboren
also wenn wir sagen der stock sieht
gebogen aus dann ist es richtig und mir
scheint der stock gebogen zu sein also
immer nur wenn ich ihn wirklich mit
these vertreten die nicht im modus des
scheint mir scheinen es verfasst ist
sondern dem ich eine ganz klare position
äußere dann kann was semantisch aber nur
bar sein ich frage mich halt ob diese
drei neuronen 20 evaluiere wachsen
darum geht es jetzt erst wenn ich
einfach die frage sind sie prinzipiell
evaluiert wenn sie oder ich nicht meine
position in uns haben dass der stock im
wasser gebogen ist dann ist das
prinzipiell evaluiert jetzt mal alle
epidemischen fragestellung außen vor
gelassen
es ist prinzipiell möglich sie können
selbst dann irgendwann merken ich habe
mich getäuscht
sie schauen nach ist der stock gebogen
tatsächlich zehn stück raus wo es nicht
ist nicht gebogen also folgt daraus dass
sie meine position war falsch das ist
prinzipiell möglich hier ist die frage
ist es überhaupt prinzipiell möglich ist
so was überhaupt evaluiert und sind so
ist eine anordnung sagen wir mal hier
1000 euro ich weiß nicht wie viel
neuronen seehase hat weiß das jemand von
ihm
ich glaube nicht besonders viele ja
die neuronen können sich ja eigentlich
nur so verändern dass es sich anders
anordnen oder beim anderen schallt
zusammenhang sich befinden also eine
andere anordnung von neuronen man kann
es denke ich daraufhin unterbrechen
neuronen sind zählbare entitäten die
irgendwie auf einen solchen reiz
reagieren müssen
wie können neuronen auf seinen reiz
reagieren sie müssen irgendwelche neuen
verbindungen knüpfen miteinander und das
habe ich jetzt einfach mal so
repräsentiert indem ich sie ihn anders
angeordnet habe die neuronen werden ja
nicht mehr oder weniger mit einem
bestimmt bestimmten besondere reiz auf
uns ein trinkt es sei denn wir bekommen
schlag auf den kopf dann sterben panoro
japans eigentlich wenn wir einen
leichten schmerz spüren bleibt die
neuronen zahl ja gleich nur man könnte
auch sagen beim seehasen leuchtet anhalt
hier kann man genauso machen die
seehasen leute inhalt blitz dann halt
hier was aus dem gehirn da blitzt was
auf und wenn bei dem blitz da was auf
und bei dem blitz da war es auch kann
man genauso topografisch sei es
letztendlich dasselbe ob man es so an
oder suchen und die frage ist halt ist
dass hier bis aufblitzen ist das
semantische evaluiert
die veränderung von deren
okay er habe ich genau dasselbe problem
hätte ich das selbe problem damit wird
wäre letztendlich glaube ich dasselbe
ist der gewinn
dadurch dass ich jetzt hier so eine
distanz haben daraus folgt auch
semantisch gar nichts ich meine man kann
natürlich sagen gut hier wird jetzt
plötzlich tritt jetzt anreiz in diesem
zentrum auf ok also im präfrontalen
kortex und der ist mit solchen
eigenschaften verbunden dann wird
semantisch interessant dann haben wir
sagen also alles was die vorne auftritt
hier das hat irgendwas mit höheren
kognitiven fähigkeiten zu tun und alles
was ihr zentrum des gehirns im inneren
hat er immer der emotion was zu tun
diese benutzung der eltern das stammhirn
oder sowas ja kann ich sagen also okay
der seehase wenn hier vorne in seinem
pre frontalen kortex wenn er denn ein
hätte austritt würde jetzt hier sich
irgendwie gedanken hoch intelligente
gedanken machen und wenn es in ihrem
zentrum ist dann hat irgendwelche
evolutionär sehr rudimentären emotionen
dabei ich weiß nicht bitte
werner spec
vorangeschritten
die reaktionen die beim niesen
richtig ist
die lerneffekte bewerben
wenn du
falsch
dann wichtig
gut also gut dass sie wieder das ganze
zurückbringen auf dieses konkrete
beispiel nämlich schutzreaktion also
funktionaler über lebenszusammenhang und
solche funktionalen überlebens
zusammenhänge sind durchaus semantisch
besser interpretierbar als nuss und
beliebiges beispiel als man kann sagen
der seehase also diese anordnung auf
diesen reiz die hat die semantische
bedeutung des schutzes also hier ist man
tickets das alte proposition hat er
natürlich nicht aber könnte man sagen es
gibt eine gefahr
das wäre die position klar darauf muss
ich reagieren oder so das wäre so eine
gefahr gefahr von vorne oder so wie bei
einem tintenfisch verticken fisch der
sendet dann diese dieses diese tinte aus
vernebelt die ganze umgebung schutz bei
der die semantische raum mehr schutz
oder oder abwehrreaktionen
das ist durchaus semantisch schon
stärker es lässt sich in seiner funktion
überlebens funktion jetzt das semantisch
denke ich doch besser interpretieren
natürlich ist trotzdem die frage die ist
es nicht doch auch nur ein input output
mechanismus könnte man ja wieder
skeptisch sagen würde die karte an das
ist einfach die maschine funktioniert
einfach so wenn das passiert dann das
als nächsten zimmern tick drin
keine mechanismus komplexer mechanismus
oder wird da jetzt so ein evolutionäres
abwehr programm abgespielt habe ich sage
ja schon ein programm das abgespielt
wird das ist sehr automatisch aber ich
denke mit ihren mit ihrem verweis auf
diese diesen funktionalen kontext haben
wir durchaus die möglichkeit das ganze
semantischen interpretieren weil es in
einer funktion steht des schutzes geht
das ins durchaus möglich gehen wir
weiter es ist recht einsichtig
wie die dritte bedingung an die
vorhergehende geknüpft ist wenn ein
indikator einmal eine funktion erworben
hat muss falsches funktionieren möglich
sein im prinzip kann die repräsentation
auch dann aktiviert werden wenn das was
sie repräsentiert abwesend ist
in die alltagssprache übersetzt heißt
das die dritte bedingung impliziert dass
ein tier mit einem geist in der lage
sein muss gelegentlich fälschlich zu
glauben dass dieser oder jener umstand
vorliegt und es muss in der lage sein
gemäß seiner überzeugung zu handeln
der leser und die leserin werden sich
vielleicht darüber wundern dass die
möglichkeit des irrtums ein derart
bedeutsamen schritt in der evolution
darstellt
diese möglichkeit wie auch die fähigkeit
den inneren zustand zu verändern wenn
der traum einmal aufgeregt wurde ist sie
doch begrifflich an die fähigkeit
gebunden geistige repräsentation zu
bilden ist ganz spannend gingen sie noch
kein donnell davidson der hat ja auch
gesagt ein irrtum ist nicht ein mangel
an vernunft sondern eine krankheit oder
eine störung der vernunft ich fand diese
metapher nicht so glücklicher weil sagte
also wird schon zeigt nicht das ist hier
nichts mit der nationalität dass es hier
nicht mit rationalität zu tun hat sind
einwirkung ist gerade ein hinweis für
das volk von rationalität finde ich ganz
spannend und sie scheint jetzt genau
dasselbe zu sagen außer
evolutionsbiologischen perspektive als
bildschirm
ich glaube ich schon dass der begriff
des betons impliziert dass es sich
hierbei um was repräsentation ahles
handelt wenn ein irrtum als solcher klar
also wird schon in seiner natürlichkeit
diagnostiziert wurde dann impliziter
sind meinen augen schon dass da was das
der repräsentation vorlegen
dann ist es eine miss repräsentation ja
wir werden uns darüber bewusst dass es
sich hierbei nicht um eine angemessene
repräsentation handelt und dann wird das
ganze korrigiert wenn so ein mechanismus
fällig also ein reagieren auf dann saß
ich glaube schon dass das faktum das
phänomen des votums
wenn es wirklich irrtum ist das ist dann
impliziert dass da eine geistige
dimension im spiel war
die frage ist dann ob der seehase oder
was auch immer glaubt dass das war aber
eigentlich schon bei einem wirt schon
muss eine position im spiel sein die
nicht also ist eigentlich nur das volk
eine position die nicht wahr ist also
ein der begriff des irrtums impliziert
dass proposition ali-t tim spielt sein
muss deswegen sagt sie glaube ich zurück
zu recht dass also zum mit
repräsentation zu tun hat also immer
wenn sie denn wirklich vorliegen sind
ganz klare indizien für geistig aktiv
glaube ich schon
die frage ist halt wirklich wie mann
sein irrtum jetzt identifiziert darum
geht es uns jetzt aber erstmal nicht wie
wir den irrtum denn feststellen können
das wäre dann wieder eine frage der
evolutionsbiologe der anthropologen oder
was auch immer
uns geht es ihr darum einfach von von
bedingungen zu sprechen also durchaus
idealen fst mission zuständen einfach
woran erkennen wir dass das volk das ist
also unsere ebene über die wir sprechen
als philosophen zum interessanten dabei
häufig wird der irrtum er also was
mangelhaftes dargestellt da wo minister
ist kein geistigkeit da ist dummheit das
ist bloße maschine stimmt nicht wenn
wirklich völlig dann muss eine
repräsentation von ligen oder eine
position die eben korrigiert wird die
nicht zutrifft was das war falsch sein
kann und das ist eben doch immer nur bei
geistigen verfall dieser weiter wenn wir
nun wieder zum fall des seehasen
zurückkehren der zweifellos auf eine
große anzahl von tieren zutrifft klar
weil ich meine so viel in rom hatten ch
ist nicht
ich weiß nicht wie viele aber durchaus
absehbar
sehen wir dass er die beiden ersten
bedingungen erfüllt das haben wir auch
unabhängig jetzt von frau post so schon
gesagt bei uns war es und ich glaube der
dritten bedingungen der seehase führt
über innere indikatoren die mit unserer
situation co variieren diese indikatoren
eigenen sich die funktion an solche
situationen anzuzeigen dabei für einen
lernprozess statt und kann jedoch nicht
sagen dass die inneren zustände
überzeugen und bilden weil die aussage
keinen sinn ergibt ein seehase sich die
neuronale ausrüstung eines seehafens
erlaubt ihm nicht eine unterscheidung
zwischen zahlen inneren zuständen zu
treffen mit und dem was diese zustände
repräsentieren das war das was sie sagt
und dass man sich das noch mal verhält
was aber sind die bedingungen die einen
glauben das sei es auch nur auf
primitive weise seine eigene zustände
von denen der umwelt zu unterscheiden
als sie hasse ist noch nicht
komplex genug um diese dritte bedingung
zu erfüllen sagt petz so hatten wir es
ja eigentlich auch gesehen
in einem kürzlich erschienen buch habe
ich vorgeschlagen die bedingungen zu
präzisieren
unter denen es zulässig ist einem
sprachlosen überzeugungen zuzuschreiben
die grundidee ist dabei folgende um wahr
oder falsch überzeugung über die welt
haben zu können muss ein organismus
zunächst über eine wahrnehmung struktur
verfügen die es ihm erlaubt den
beobachter der selber ist in einer welt
von wahrgenommen gegenständen und
ereignissen zu situieren die wir oben
gesehen haben ist eine repräsentation
geistig zu wenn sie es ermöglicht die
welt richtig oder falsch zu
repräsentieren
diese erstaunliche fähigkeit scheint auf
die eine oder andere weise die fähigkeit
vorauszusetzen aus sich heraus zu gehen
um die welt zu erreichen das heißt die
fähigkeit auf eigenschaften der welt zu
reagieren und nicht einfach auf einen
proxy malen zustand gerät zu toren des
organismus
also ja
nein
von hier
und 2
innerer indikator
wenn ich einfach dass
wieso
ich denke schon dass der punkt 3 also
der punkt 3 wesentlich mit mit
proposition zu tun hat also
repräsentationen irrtümer die ja hier
geht es rein kommen semantisch evaluiere
sachen die müssen immer proportional
vorliegt also ich denke es ist so die
hänge miteinander zusammen
[Musik]
ich denke man kann es ja sie möchte das
einfach anhand eines beispiels genauer
veranschaulichen
sie möchte ich sagen wenn ich direkt
verstehen anhand von irrtümern am
phänomen des teams können wir zeigen
dass daraus folgt dass proposition
vorhandenen zahlen müssen
das gehört alles in diesem topf von
punkt 3 würde ich sagen
auch mit semantischer
essen
die muss man nur ein
ja ich denke es geht an den haben
tierheims giganten hand also ein irrtum
ist nicht ohne positionen möglich würde
ich sagen
richtig ja richtig ja aber ich schon
aber ich meine man kann zum beispiel
jetzt doch ein phänomen feststellen dass
hinter der irrt und das sind ihren
fehler korrigiert einfach phänomenal
wir beobachten irgendwie ein affe und
oder sind hier wo es ziemlich klar ist
dass die ziemlich intelligent sind und
wir merken dass die sich selbst
korrigieren
als wir merkten dass und wie
interpretieren ist zumindest zu
und wenn wir dann feststellen dass sie
also sich selbst in ihrem dass sie
selbst ihre repräsentation korrigieren
dann können wir daraus natürlich
schließen dass sie eine positive
proposition besitzen also es geht dann
glaube ich darum begrifflich müssen wir
natürlich begrifflich oder logisch
müssen wir damit schon möglich ist
repräsentationen und proposition
voraussetzen aber ästhetisch oder mit
ökologisch ist glaube ich so dass wir
erst vom heer auf die proposition
schließen dann
könnte ja das aus
ja genau
genau richtig richtig das ist dann die
systemische problematik ist es wirklich
aber wir haben eben in manchen fällen zb
bei affen oder bei denen also sehr gute
gründe um davon ausgehen dass sie ihr
job begehen und dass sie den korrigieren
also dass man zum beispiel etwas
korrigiert das dann eben noch mal eine
handlung vollzogen wird wo dieser fall
wirklich intentional ausgelassen wird
oder anders nun gewinnt wird wo also das
gesamte setting dasselbe ist mit
ausnahme dieses falls wo daneben kommt
tatsächlich nur eine kleine varianz ist
dann haben wir glaube ich gute gründe
von der korrektur zu sprechen ja
wir bleiben
also da
zu machen und sich absolut
weil
also nicht
werde möglich also dass wir natürlich
noch eine höhere stufe dann aber ich
denke mein tier was der sumo korrigieren
kann könnte prinzipien auch anderen eine
falle stellen
aber alles hat ein es hat eine
proposition es hat das bewusstsein davon
dass eine position nicht vorliegt und da
könnte dann darauf aufbauend sowas
erfolgen wie eine systematische
täuschung gibt er den fall dass tiere
andere tiere täuschen es gibt es ja
die partie vor
ja aber bei krems und mein spiel dafür
da finden wieder sorgen
oder für die feststellung
für unsere äußere etliche beobachter
perspektive vom logischen oder einer
phänomenalen gehalt nicht da könnte zum
vorliegen ohne dass er korrigiert wird
aber häufig sieht man eben bei tieren
dass sie ihre ersten mal auch
korrigieren
also einfach von der außenperspektive
und das gibt uns dann anlass dazu
anzunehmen dass hier irrtum bemerkt
wurde das ist schon wirklich vorlag
es kann natürlich auch sein tiere
begeben oder ohne sie zu korrigieren
ganz klar das ist durchaus möglich wenn
man eben ein guter punkt mit dem hund
der den baum da an welt prima fazit
würden davon ausgeht dass ein irrtum
begeht das eine falsche repräsentation
hat das ist ja dieses beispiel american
gewesen hat der hund jetzt da eine
falsche repräsentation also ist die
repräsentation der hat katze ist auf dem
baum ist die einfach falsch und hat sagt
eben donnell davidson
es ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich dass
eine opposition hat weil eben das ganze
holistisch erfasst sein müsste merkel
sagt nein es ist so wie wenn wir den
schlüssel unserer hosentasche suchen
muss man jetzt unentschieden lassen erst
mal ich meine man könnte zum beispiel
folgendes experiment dann machen wenn
man eine wenn der hund sie hatten das
beigebracht mit dieser platte nadi
einfach hängen geblieben ist und der
computer der irgendwie hängengeblieben
ist und wenn dann die katze plötzlich
wieder auftaucht dann wäre es nicht so
zu interpretieren dass der hund selbst
korrigiert sondern läuft die platte
einfach weiter da wo es eben stehen
geblieben war der hund hatte keine
orientierung bis er die katze wieder sie
dann folgte
ich muss jetzt erstmal offen lassen habe
ich glaube bei kräne und so kann man
wirklich gut zeigen dass sie ihren
fehler korrigieren und dann können wir
glaube ich gute gründe anführen dafür
dass sie eine art von repräsentation
hatten beim hund müssen wir uns noch
offen lassen das ist richtig
ja als ich glaube ja wir müssen eben
unterscheiden also einmal diese
verifikation aale ebene wo wir als
beobachter tatsächlich entscheiden
können und diese ebene die begriffliche
ebene
was muss vorliegen damit ein irrtum
vorhanden ist wir bewegen uns jetzt nur
auf der begrifflichen ebene nicht auf
der entscheidungsebene
neben der repräsentation und ihre
position dass hier eben offen dass man
davon ausgehen kann oder man einfach mal
ausgeht hier ist eine repräsentation
vorhanden und die repräsentation die
repräsentiert eben nicht richtig also
sind ist eine fährverbindung
richtig aber die frage eben ist eine
antwort wie wir das jetzt feststellen
können ob es da eine repräsentanz
repräsentation gibt also die tatsache
dass es schon gibt also wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass es schon gibt dann müssen
wir davon ausgehen dass es eine
außenwelt gibt die objektiv ist und der
entsprochen werden kann auch nicht
entsprochen werden kann das ist klar
aber eine andere frage ist es eben ob
wir tatsächlich feststellen können dass
jetzt in diesem fall ein irrtum vorliegt
und das sehen sagen wir schon beim hund
ist ziemlich schwierig das ist dann aber
eben davon zu unterscheiden weil dann
wirklich der empirische faktoren mit
rein kommen und hier scheint mir alles
noch auf dieser begrifflichen ebene zu
sein wenn ich mich nicht irre
immer noch mal hier auf die zeit zurück
um eine wahre der falsche überzeugung zu
haben
über die welt zu haben
du musst ein organismus zunächst über
eine wahrnehmung struktur verfügen die
es ihm erlaubt den beobachter der er
selber ist in einer welt von
wahrgenommen gegenstände und ereignisse
zu situieren also wir haben ja wieder
was holistische also hier geht es glaube
ich kann's gehen ich so ein bisschen wie
bei davidson darum dass man nicht
getrennt ist von der umgebung wahr und
falsch muss repräsentiert werden können
und man muss aus sich herausgehen um die
wiltzer reichen
und das scheint bei einem seehasen
schwierig zu sagen jedenfalls es
erweitert die philosophen nennen diese
fähigkeit objektivität
das ist übrigens bei donner davidson
auch so nicht in diesem text den wir
jetzt gelesen haben ein bisschen auch
sinn dieser stelle die wir nicht mehr
gelesen haben geht es auch um so eine
welt die alle kommunikationspartner
teilen dadurch wird objektivität
erreicht tunnel davidson hat in einem
anderen aufsatz ein sogenanntes
triangulation modell entwickelt also wie
eine triangel
das heißt für ihn geht es immer darum
objektivität nie immer nur zwischen
subjekt und objekt eben auch durch inter
subjektivität durch kommunikation mit
anderen
dadurch wird objektivität erlangen durch
solistische system von gegenseitigen
stützungen wir mit bezug auf die welt
mit bezug auf andere
kommunikationspartner in einer
sprachgemeinschaft und diese drei
parteien die stützen die objektivität
wieso dreyfus sagt er
und so nennt scheint sie es auch zu
verstehen also objektivität ist etwas
was starke voraussetzung hat die
philosophen denn diese fähigkeit
objektivität darunter ist das vermögen
zu verstehen das was die erfahrung des
subjekts betrifft von dem zu
unterscheiden was das subjekt was das
objekt seiner erfahrung betrifft im
alltags verständnis geht man das problem
der objektivität mit hervor indem man
räumliche und funktionale
betrachtungsweisen miteinander vermischt
man stellt einfach eine position her
zwischen dem was sich drinnen und
draußen abspielt oder zwischen dem was
zum system und zur umwelt gehört das
alltags verständnis begeht aber den
fehler einer petition prinzipien als
eines zirkusses wenn es sich auf eine
besondere präsentation beruft auf die
opposition ihnen außen oder allgemeiner
freundliche begriffe und die
repräsentation fähigkeiten eines nicht
menschlichen geistes zu erklären
räumliche begriffe können nämlich nur
dann eine lösung bieten wenn es darum
geht die verbindung von räumlichen
relations' unterscheidung von begriffen
zu erklären wie soll man das erklären
was es dem raum ermöglicht von einem
organismus gleichsam verinnerlicht zu
werden und was bewirkt dass der ganze
prozess der bildung von geistigen
repräsentationen durch den der scheidung
von innen und außen bestimmt wird
lesen macht weiter und zwar jetzt geht
es hier um die frage ob tiere über
begriffe verfügen also nochmal
zusammengefasst zur vorherigen kann man
sagen also damit wirklich geistige
repräsentation vorlegen muss wie sie
sagten muss man sich zu sich selbst
verhalten können oder muss man so eine
art von objektivität haben die eben wie
sie dies im c2 126 27 sagte eben etwas
voraussetzt dass man aus sich herausgeht
und die welt was man wirklich auf
eigenschaft der welt reagiert nicht
einfach auf einen proxy malen zustand
der rezeption des organismus
also das war irgendwie hat sich eine
situation begibt die nicht mehr nur
diese innerlichkeit betrifft und jetzt
stellt sich die frage ob tiere über
begriffe verfügen die bisherigen
ausführungen erlauben die aussage dass
wahrscheinlich zahlreiche nicht
menschliche lebewesen geistige
repräsentation haben wenn man
repräsentation anhand der drei oben
erwähnten bedingungen von treitschke
definiert sie nehmen die welt als eine
zusammensetzung aus entitäten war die im
raum verteilt sind und über eine gewisse
eigengesetzlichkeit verfügen
gleichzeitig sind die repräsentationen
die sie auf der grundlage ihrer
wahrnehmung bilden auch objektiv dies
verleiht ihnen etwa eigene überzeugung
ihren etwaigen überzeugung die fähigkeit
semantisch evaluiert zu sein das heißt
war oder falsch okay also die dritte
bedingung sagt jetzt frau post die ist
wohl auch bei sehr vielen lebewesen
nichtmenschlichen
vorhanden wenn eben beim entitäten im
raum verteilt wahrgenommen werden
also wenn die relation eine rolle
spielen
also wenn es eben koordination gibt eben
entitäten im raum in ihrer relation
ali-t präsentiert werden
wenn es also wirklich um die äußeren
verhältnisse geht und nicht nur um die
inneren verhältnisse sagt sie oder habe
ich sie falsch verstanden
die dame ist oder wie sehen sie es
ich hab proxy muss ist als annäherungs
annäherungsweise gehen wir noch mal
zurück
ja ja ja also ich denke wir haben schon
repräsentationen also wie wir es
natürlich registrieren wir objekte von
außen aber das sind da nicht nur im
reaktionen die der nahe kommen bereits
seien wir zum beispiel wir halten ihnen
maria g nicht unmittelbar auf
irgendwelche reize wie halten inne
wir haben repräsentationen die nicht mit
diesem reiz reaktions stehen wir
unmittelbar dann verwendet werden
sondern wir können uns sagte davon
distanzieren
wir können also ist das problem ist also
der punkt ist dass objektivität scheint
was sie wie sie es in diesem zitat sagt
nicht um bloße das scheint nichts mit
bloßer rezept ivi tat zu tun zu haben
diese reaktion oder vor allem
unmittelbare reaktion dieser proxy mal
zustand sondern hier spielt die
reflexionen wollen die reflexion die
reflexion sich zurückzuziehen aus diesem
reiz reaktions schwimmer und in dieser
distanz zu diesen unmittelbaren reizen
geben die außenwelt mehr zur geltung
kommen zu lassen ich glaube dass das
wesentliche was mit dieser reflexivität
tun hat nicht unmittelbar auf reize
reagieren zu müssen war etwas
zurückzutreten und dann die welt in ihre
objektivität erst zur geltung zu nehmen
ja
ist
und
neben
valverde zu verstehen
holz stark machen
hier sollen
müssen ja können
schon auch so eine möglichkeit
ja genau schematismus ein guter punkt
indem ich ein schema anwende reagiere
ich nicht nur unmittelbar auf reiz
reaktions schimmert also ist auch ein
schema natürlich als reaktion habe ich
habe hier nicht nur drei mal ruhen sind
ich habe hier ein schema was in mir
selbst ist ein konzept ein welt konzept
habe ich aber ein welt konzept was ich
vielleicht auch flexibel anlegen kann
als es scheint hier wenn ich sie recht
versteht die autorin eben darum zu gehen
dass repräsentation distanzierung
voraussetzt distanzierung von den
unmittelbar heizen wenn ich zu
unmittelbaren den reizen trennen bin
kann ich es nicht repräsentieren
ich brauche praktisch freiheit der
repräsentation ich brauche genug distanz
zu den auf mich ein prasselnden reizen
um dann hier auf dieser ebene hier
repräsentation bilden zu können oder
nicht
wie verstehen sie es
sie selbst war
die steht der seehase sowieso nicht der
seehasen macht es nicht aber wir denke
ich schon auch andere tiere sagt sie in
die wir eben nicht mehr hier nur jetzt
hier 3 da muss wesentlich komplexere
sind uns im gehirn vorgehen als nur so
eine neuronale wandlung und es darf auch
nicht so verstanden werden wenn ich sie
recht verstehen dass man unmittelbar aus
reagiert sagt dass da mehr im gehirn
passiert
indem ich abstrahieren indem ich
abstrahieren
wenn es nicht so ist
durch selbstbewusstsein zum beispiel
durch selbstbewusstsein also
selbstbewusstsein wäre zum beispiel
als in dem ich ihn
als sie zum beispiel wenig eben ein sehr
ausgeprägter würde ich das jetzt
unterstützen sie haben natürlich recht
das ist sehr sehr verknappt gesagt war
also das ist sehr knapp ihren
danach stellten
wir maßnahmen ist ein 2
also muss seinen organismus zunächst
über einen wahrnehmungs struktur
verfügen die es ihm erlaubt in
beobachter die er selber ist in einer
welt von weiteren gegenständen und
ereignissen zu situieren das heißt da
ist so eine art von schwachen
selbstbewusstsein notwendig ich verhalte
mich selbst in der welt in der diese
reize auf mich einströmt
ich bin nicht nur die muschel
ja es ist
ja richtig aber es aus dem aus dem
komplexen organismus das ja gar nicht
schlimm wenn die repräsentation auch
neuronal realisiert sind
es geht hier einfach um wesentlich
komplexere neuronale zustimmen
die geben es erlauben höhere
objektivität zu erreichen weil das
individuum das organisch fast individuum
sagen wir aus sich heraus treten kann in
der neuronalen repräsentation natürlich
die neuronale repräsentation ist so
komplex dass es sich selbst im
wechselspiel der welt begreift und nicht
nur als ein objekt das nur phänomenales
bewusstsein hat und darauf reagiert
hier aus hat man meistens
letztendlich schon aber ich meine es
natürlich folgendes sagen also ich
glaube nicht dass man repräsentationen
nur durch neuronen angemessen an geben
darf das ist der entscheidende punkt
hier hier haben sie haben naja sie sagt
jetzt hier nicht mehr direkt mit euro
untersagt sitzen nicht mehr also das
haben wir waren jetzt in diesem beispiel
beim ch seine eine ganz schwache form
von repräsentationen können wir sagen
ist eine anordnung von meiner wohnung
aber wir haben ja gesehen beim dritten
punkt der dritte punkt der den stern
scheidende punkt ist semantisch
evaluiert der greift beim ch es nicht
mehr sagt sie ja selber dass sie ja sie
ist dafür nicht hinreichen das heißt wir
müssen dann wirklich auf eine andere
ebene gehe und natürlich sind
repräsentationen neuronal irgendwie
korrelieren neuronal mit und mit
gewissen zuständen des gehirns aber sie
sind natürlich nicht identisch damit das
ist auch noch ein wichtiger punkt also
repräsentation denke ich dürfen wir
nicht als identisch verstehen diesen
riesen debatte in der philosophie des
geistes sind in psychischer zustände
wirklich identisch mit neuronalen
zuständen
ich glaube dass es nicht der fall als
ich glaube dass wir nicht erklären
können wie eine überzeugung dass also
wie diese plattform wie die sich
neuronale widerspiegeln das meint sie
wahrscheinlich nicht
das kann man nicht erklären glaube ich
jedenfalls also mir leuchtet es nicht
ein zu sagen wir mal hier jede über
jedes neue jeder punkten 33 millionen
und 3 milliarden neuronen jetzt sie also
drei milliarden euro haben führen zu
dieser struktur das iks
das kann ich nicht ich sehe da keine
verbindung also ich glaube wir müssen
unterscheiden
das eine ist das neuronale korrelat das
mag irgendwie wieder oben eine
repräsentation repräsentieren irgendwie
aber es ist nicht identisch sagt ich
glaube das kann man durchaus so anja ist
nicht identisch starten
die frage bleibt natürlich offen was
dann wieder an eine repräsentation sich
neuronale irgendwie das manifestiert
aber hier ist jetzt nicht mehr auf der
ebene der neuronen sie waren nur bei
punkt 1.2 auf der ebene der neuron als
es um den seehasen gibt hier geht's um
die semantisch evaluieren phänomen und
da sagt sie einfach nur repräsentation
begriffe und das entscheidende scheint
für sie das zu sein dass man eben ein
gewisses selbstbewusstsein entwickelt
und dass man sich jedenfalls aus sich
heraus reflektiert und sich selbst
koordiniert in der außen- will dass man
sich selbst in ein verhältnis bringt zu
anderen individuen zu anderen objekten
nach außen und nicht nur der bloße
empfänger von reizen ist man darauf
reagiert dann so ein bisschen spontan
auch wird nach außen hin agiert ich
glaube das ist für sie der entscheidende
punkt lesen wir mal ganz kurz noch ein
bisschen weiter haben nicht mehr viel
zeit die bisherigen ausführungen genau
also sagte sie
das wahrscheinlich zahlreiche nicht
menschen die lebewesen geistige
repräsentation haben ok
das semantische angepasst und die daraus
folgende frage lautet offenbar ob diese
tiere die zur bildung einer art von
proto überzeugungen fähig sind auch
wirkliche überzeugung hervorbringt das
heißt begrifflich artikulierte
überzeugung oder ob sie nur über nicht
begriffliche wahrnehmungsfähigkeiten
verfügen das heißt ob sie sich darauf
beschränken wahrgenommen eine formen und
ereignisse zu kategorisieren wie wir
noch sehen werden liegt der unterschied
zwischen begriffen und einfachen
wahrnehmung darin dass erstere in
frentzen ermöglichen und dadurch eine
form von rationalität begründen wird ein
wahrnehmungs gehalt an sich einem tier
noch nicht erlaubt an überzeugung an zu
stören dass leute doch eigentlich recht
ein also einen wahrnehmungs inhalt ist
noch nicht unbedingt proposition ahl
verfasst sie spricht jetzt hier von
proto überzeugungen mustererkennung
mehrere zum beispiel so ein fall von
komplexer wahrnehmen wahrnehmung jetzt
nicht nur im sinne der kunden reiz und
ich reagiere darauf sondern da konnten
reiz und ich sie tue ihre diesen reiz im
kontext von anderen reizen
also ich habe diesen zusammenhang von
verschiedenen reizen
es bildet sich bereits muster aus nicht
nur der einzelne weit sind ich ordne
diese reize die auf mich ein strömen auf
eine bestimmte weise an sodass
objektivität ermöglicht wird sein reizen
muster zu bilden sagt sie ist noch nicht
dasselbe wie pro positionen zu haben
oder überzeugungen zu haben weil
überzeugungen oder präpositionen wie
schon doppelt davidson sagte immer es
ermöglichen dass man davon schlüsse
ableitet anderes ableitet sie nennt das
ganze in frentzen in vereinen sind
schlussfolgerung ableitung aus gewissen
überzeugung also aus der überzeugung
dass es folgt die überzeugung dass nicht
exelon zb das wäre auf basis von großen
komplexen wahrnehmungsmuster nicht
möglich sagt sie da ist keine
nationalität drin trotzdem sagt sie
können wird das komplexen warenimporte
überzeugung wenn also proto als im sinne
von vorläufigen oder basalen oder
primitiven überzeugung so einige
philosophen jetzt kommt er unter ihnen
der harley davidson haben die these
verteidigt dass tiere die nicht über
sprache verfügen aufgrund dieser
tatsachen notwendigerweise keine
begriffe haben
es ist bekannt wie die karts die idee
dass tiere belegen können zurückwies
eine idee die montani den wir auch schon
behandelt haben am herzen lag
tiere lösen die probleme die sich ihnen
stellen nämlich nicht dadurch dass sie
ihre erkenntnisse und ihre prinzipien
einer natürlichen logik miteinander
verbinden
vielmehr sind sie aufgrund eines
angeborenen verhaltens gleichsam darauf
festgelegt diese probleme zu lösen im
gegensatz zu dass zu den situativen
lösungen zu denen die tiere einen zugang
haben fügen menschen aufgrund ihrer
vernunft über ein allgemeines
instrumentarium zur problemlösung
sprache bietet ihnen dafür dass
erforderliche mittel weil sie der
kombination von zeichen der gemeinheit
hinzufügt die allgemeinheit zufügt die
für das denken charakteristisch ist das
ist jetzt eine paraphrase von descartes
eigentlich nur die karte das auch gesagt
ein allgemeines instrumentarium die
sprache das ist das universal vermögen
von dem die karte gesprochen hatte was
die mittel und die flexibilität besitzt
auf ganz verschiedene situationen zu
antworten
donna davidson bestreitet dass tiere ein
zugang zum denken haben indem er sich
eine strategie die sich nur wenige von
denen wenig von derjenigen descartes
unterscheidet das haben wir die letzten
sitzung auch schon passieren
er geht von der unbestreitbaren annahme
aus dass begriffe zu verwenden heißt
semantische evaluiere gedanken zu haben
jetzt endlich auch im ferenc am bilden
zu können schlüsse ableiten zu können
so kann er beispielsweise nicht den
begriff briefträger verwenden ohne auf
eine gewisse zahl von charakteristischer
zurückzugreifen die zu recht die aussage
erlauben dass dieses oder jenes
individuum ein briefträger ist und dies
zu tun muss ein begriff verwenden jedoch
notwendigerweise was ich selbst
repräsentieren können dass der begriff
dinge unter den gegebenen bedingungen
auf ein individuum anwendet etwa indem
er denkt dies ist der briefträger zu
unrecht also um korrekt angewendet
werden kann und das zu erreichen muss in
der lage sein seine begriffs verwendung
mit einem anderen zu teilen
und aus diesen gegenseitigen austausch
eine bestätigung für seine begriffs
verwendung zu gewinnen im falle des
scheiterns muss ist eine rationalen
einspruch gegen die rechtmäßigkeit
seiner verbindung geben
das ist jetzt also wieder das schon sehr
anspruchsvoll hier geht es jetzt um
inter subjektivität die sowas erst
ermöglicht jetzt repräsentiert jetzt
passiert sie dass ein bisschen ich lese
mal das letzte zutat vor weil sie sich
nämlich jetzt ein bisschen skeptisch
gegenüber diesen auffassung verhält wie
gehen aber das nächste mal aber kurz
darauf ein sagt ganz am schluss es ist
kein überspannte annahme dass gewisse
nicht menschliche lebewesen begriffe
bögen können die ihren jene aspekte der
umgebung verständlich machen die für sie
am wichtigsten sind möglicherweise für
verfüge soziale tiere hunde primaten zu
weit über theorien für die organisation
sozialer beziehungen
diese theorien enthalten begriffe für
dominante und untergeordnet hierfür
junge freunde verbündete und sie
enthalten auch die in ferenczy allen und
assoziativen verknüpfungen zwischen
diesen kategorien für das zahlen von
nahrungs schutz gegen einen raub an die
partnersuche und so weiter also lesen
das nächste mal diese übersprungen
passagen noch ein bisschen genauer sie
scheint jetzt darauf zu kommen so eine
art von proto überzeugungen bei
nichtmenschlichen gewesen anzunehmen
die dafür dass sich eignen dass man hier
auch in ferienziele und assoziativ
verknüpfungen herstellen und das ist so
wieder ganz im sinne von donnell
davidson der gesagt hat die solis muss
muss eine rolle spielen police muss hat
immer was mit schlüssen zu tun die
daraus gezogen werden
als sie sagt am ende tiere nicht
menschliche lebewesen die haben durchaus
so was was donner davidson fordert und
das ist nicht überspannen das ist also
durchaus realistisch und damit haben wir
jetzt eine gegenposition zu descartes
und auch zur doppel davidson
wir lesen diesen text der nächsten
sitzung bisschen weiter und werden dann
aber denke ich zum schluss noch auf john
searle zu sprechen kommt ja auch eine
ganz interessante linguistische theorie
über die nationalität der tiere
gegründet hat dann bis zum nächsten
sitzung